[Music]
dad you woke up from your coma oh god
what did I miss
well I'm really glad you asked because I
got into movies are you gonna tell me
about the movies that I missed I've been
in a coma a long time oh I just saw
spider-man another one with a head you
Garfield no it's a reboot with Tom
Holland a three boot we get it
his uncle's dead what else is out I
don't know kong-kong pick up that
sticker with Jack Black they made
another one oh no it's a second reboot
and then the next one he's gonna like
fight Godzilla okay they're three Billy
King Kong and Godzilla Jesus Christ we
get it hey della copters what else came
out The Mummy now will you please just
listen to me The Mummy with Brendan
Fraser no with Tom Cruise okay they
three booted that - are you happy never
Tom Cruise no ray boats a movie with all
the back toes shut
uh I got a scholarship to an Ivy League
school are you proud of me
look I ain't buying the sweatshirt in
it's not personal
I'm very proud of you thank you for I've
just been in the Cobo very long time I
don't know what else this three booted I
hate three boots what else came out Lego
Batman okay Lego Batman and Justice
League is coming out this year -
rebooting truth black bags at the same
time by god we get it easily Oh dad Oh
God jeez stay back clear
oh no two's enough cuz uh he hates three
months hey hard part I went there to own
away yeah near Boston alumni yeah I love
their same Adams beer oh yeah me too so
good yeah
you